hey what's up guys mkbhd here so
wireless earbuds
if you're going to get rid of the
headphone jack you might as well make
them good right but as far as like the
de facto standard wireless earbuds for
android you'd think google would make
the best ones and when they finally got
rid of the headphone jack and the pixel
they did make the first pixel buds
but
they weren't that good they're pretty
disappointing honestly they had the
cable between them they had missing
features they weren't very comfortable
so i never really recommended them but
now these
these are the new
2020 pixel buds maybe you've seen them
by now and they are
way better they are miles better than
the previous ones that wasn't a very
high bar to clear but they vaulted so
far up they're now in my top three
favorite wireless earbuds period so i'll
share that list at the end of this video
but let's talk about what they did so
much better and why so the big bullet
points for these are they're 179 they
have a five hour battery life and they
don't have noise cancellation so
actually on the surface with just those
specs they're not that impressive at all
right you know pretty average battery
life and no noise cancellation like some
of the other premium buds so what makes
them so good and honestly it's just that
they nail all the fundamentals like
really well and they've just been rock
solid to use so you can start off with
the case here it's a sweet soft touch
matte finish and i like this white one
and it's got a black and white contrast
like like the panda pixel basically
there's matching lights one on the
inside and one on the outside and the
buds just go right in and snap
satisfyingly into place with the magnets
pretty easily and they're strong magnets
so they're easy to get out but once you
snap them in they're not going anywhere
and it's got this satisfying
snap shut with the magnets and the hinge
a lot of them have this but not all of
them do the old fabric ones definitely
didn't so this is sweet and it's just
small it's just a little small little
pebble case it's really pocketable it's
around the same size same volume as an
airpods pro case if you've seen that
before and it's just as thin so on the
spectrum of different case sizes for
wireless buds these are really nice that
makes a big difference for me as far as
how often i want to carry them around
and actually use them basically if they
can fit in the tiny pocket inside the
main pocket in my jeans i'm in i'll
carry these but then on top of all of
that it's a usb type-c port on the
bottom for wired charging and there's
also wireless charging so you can drop
them on a wireless charger where the
coils line up like this nomad one or any
flat one but ironically not the pixel
stand by google
um or on the back of any phone that
supports reverse wireless charging okay
pause
just that right there just in this new
case is a lot more than many other
wireless buds can say you know so many
times the case is too big or it's not a
high quality build like this is a nice
case wireless charging usb type c all
this together
that's nice so then we get to the buds
these are also white uh if you want to
go a little more low-key there is also a
black version and some other colors
coming soon but they're also very small
to the point where the super low profile
in my ear is a nice selling point they
don't stick out very far at all like it
basically just looks like a little disc
in your ear there's no stem
and they stay in my ears really well
thanks to these little mini wingtip
things now these are permanently
attached to the buds so they're part of
the actual earbud unlike some of the
jaybirds i've liked in the past that are
much more adjustable
and you know everybody's ears are
different so it's hard to say if this
will work for everyone but they're a
great fit for me you set them in place
and you just kind of twist them into
your ear and they lock into your ear and
they're not going anywhere and comfort
is also very good i'm using the medium
size rubber tips that came with them and
they work great
the longest i usually have you know
headphones in in a row is maybe three
or four hours tops for like a flight or
something and that's that's about as
long as i'd wear these although i know
some people keep their headphones in
like all day to work in a coffee shop
and i think that's pushing it for these
the wing tip at that point starts to
feel like kind of a pressure point
but as far as others i've tried the rock
solid lock in my ear and the shape of
them is great and again way better than
the previous pixel buds but then the
other scenario for me is working out in
them and i've gotten
really picky about workout headphones
and i tried i did i worked out in these
i went running in them
and they stay in my ears 100
that's true
but i still prefer the jaybirds with the
bigger soft wingtip those just feel
more secure and comfortable in my ear
but if you do want to double these as
workout headphones they do stay in the
ear and of course the upside is the
pixel buds are also ipx4 water resistant
so if you want to go work out in them
they'll survive some sweat or some rain
if you go running outdoors so all that
is great so
how do they sound that's the big
question with these a lot of people have
had some mixed opinions on them to keep
it perfectly simple
they sound pretty great i'm a fan of the
sound these guys have 12 millimeter
drivers that give great detail and
volume even some impressive instrument
separation if you're just like sitting
still and just listening which i did for
a while
no weird issues or anything with the
sound and they're compatible with a
great variety of stuff now i think the
downside some people will have is the
bass is lacking a little bit of punch
you know it's a little bit lighter on
the bass now this is fine for watching
videos and phone calls and podcasts but
a lot of people are used to more bass
when listening to music you know if
you've come from like beats or something
else with heavier bass so you might
prefer a bit of a different sound now
this is typically where i'd say okay go
ahead and head into the eq and add some
bass back but there is no eq built into
the pixel buds app so that's definitely
something to keep in mind if you know
what kind of sound you really like but i
think the main thing to keep in mind
here as far as sound is these are not
active noise-canceling headphones uh
they are what's called passive noise
isolating which basically just means uh
the physical seal that it makes in your
ear is all you get and i guess
really i don't mind too much that they
don't have it like it would be nice you
know on one hand the noise cancellation
i've heard from the 2 to 300 350 earbuds
like airpods pro
sony
wf-1000xm3s you know those those more
expensive ones it's really nice and they
sound better
but these do undercut them quite a bit
in price so
i guess i can't be too mad especially
when i do everything else so well okay
extra features so there's a lightweight
pixel buds app that you install during
the setup process when you first pair
these buds on your phone and you get
some nice little extras down in there
first of all it lays out and lets you
learn all the swiping and tapping
controls on the buds works on both sides
for media and they're pretty easy to
learn swipe forward or backward for
volume one tap to play pause two taps to
skip forward triple tap to go back
and a long press to pull up google
assistant i found this pretty intuitive
the only downside is the buds are so
small that you know when i was first
learning these headphones i would like
miss the earbud and i'd like kind of hit
the back of it and almost knock it out
of my ear when i'm trying to swipe uh
but i've gotten used to that over time
and let me tell you having the google
assistant in your ear all the time
pretty sweet you just say the keyword
i'm not going to say it out loud but you
just say that and suddenly you're asking
it questions all the time and there's
just something that feels like the
future about putting your finger up to
your ear like an fbi agent and just
asking it a random question and getting
an answer in your ear even if i do just
keep asking it the weather over and over
again i love it
there's also a feature called adaptive
sound which is basically supposed to
change the volume of your media
automatically
based on the loudness of the environment
you're in
but i haven't been in an environment
loud enough to see if this really works
well so i don't know i just leave this
off and i swipe to change the volume
myself
and the awesome case i talked about also
does quick charge so if you find the
battery is about to die and you have a
little bit of a quick break pop them in
the case for 10 minutes and you get two
more hours of listening time out of it
and that gives you a 24 hours total with
the buds and the case battery when it
comes down to it i really like these
earbuds i think they're enough to to
turn me into the wearing earbuds
everywhere i go guy you know i've never
really been that person you see people
walk around with airpods like 100 of the
time um
i guess it's something about this
quarantine life of being able to walk
around the house
with your earbuds in but your phone's
upstairs but you can still call up the
assistant and listen to a podcast
it's kind of nice and as a bonus there
is no noticeable bluetooth lag when
watching videos with the headphones or
playing games or anything like that
which is awesome
and you constantly also know your
battery life thanks to the app which may
give you a bit of anxiety but i find it
helpful but it really just nails the
fundamentals across the board biggest
downside i think
is no noise cancellation but you know
for people who have used passive noise
isolating earbuds before we know if you
turn the volume up loud enough you can't
really hear anything else around you
anyway
i wouldn't fly with these because it
doesn't have noise cancellation but
that's just me also the battery life
is average-ish and i think if they did
do noise cancellation with these
the battery life would have gotten even
worse
and that would have been pretty bad
maybe later they'll do a some next gen
or a more premium
pixel buds pro
and they'll be 279 and the noise
cancellation and bigger battery i could
see that but until then these new 2020
pixel buds
nice uh there are some my favorite
airpods right now right alongside i'll
go this is top three along with airpods
pro
and galaxy buds plus from samsung they
are above the sennheisers that i love so
much even though the sennheisers sound
better
because this is so much smaller and more
portable and more likely for me to use
it so well done google thumbs up for the
pixel buds this is my review unit i'm
going to be sending it back but i will
be buying a pair and i think making them
my everyday headphones um but let me
know what you think are you are you a
headphones everywhere kind of person
and if so would you get pixel buds or
let me know what you think in the
comment section below
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace